there is a new world power
[Music]
will fall
I think we're vulnerable
and welcome to find out
get tickets now holding beaters November
11th
[Music]
audiences have embraced wakanda and
black panther
and the chat with he knew exactly what
the story what these images meant to the
world
we all suffered an incredible loss when
we lost Chadwick Chad was very much our
artistic partner I would spend time with
him just he and I talking about where we
want to see the story go how much he
admired to other characters and the
actors that portrayed them
and the telling of this story you were
all able to honor him together it was
really moving to come back to wakanda
and for us to be able to do it with a
sense of Celebration
there's so much that's happening in this
movie it's amazing so many new
characters to explore just seeing the
world of wakanda again and then now
we're going to this whole new world
underwater
the name where it was a character we
were really excited to portray in the
film arguably one of the oldest comic
book characters that there is the
opportunity to play a character like
this it's a dream he's the king of an
underwater civilization called talukan
he is regarded as a living God
I need to know if wakanda is an ally or
an enemy
the level of care creating this story it
is astounding and so it just really felt
like for all of us to give it everything
we have and more I'm just so grateful
and blessed to be a part of this the
actors were filled with emotion and
passion I am queen of the most powerful
nation and my entire family is gone
all together we ended up using those
feelings to create something really
special
the action and adventure with the
emotional Stakes so high things are
happening up down and everywhere
I'm so excited about the world being
able to tap into wakanda again
how each character takes on new
challenges
and I'm excited about us honoring Chad
yeah he would want us to just Inspire
the world
[Applause]
thank you